ahora sabemos cómo encontrar el torque
pero para qué nos sirve el torque bueno
aquí hay una cosa para la que nos sirve
nosotros sabemos de la segunda ley de
newton que la aceleración es
proporcional a la fuerza algo que nos
gustaría tener es un análogo para la
rotación de esta fórmula algo que nos
diga que si tenemos cierta cantidad de
aceleración angular para cierta cantidad
de torque probablemente podríamos
adivinar que esta aceleración angular va
a tener algo probablemente como el
torque aquí arriba ya que el torque va a
ocasionar que algo se acelere angular
mente y en la parte de abajo quizá tenga
alguna masa quizás no pero es lo que
necesitamos encontrar aquí si tuviéramos
una fórmula análoga a la segunda ley de
newton pero para el torque entonces
podríamos encontrar cuál es la
aceleración angular de la misma manera
que aquí arriba si conocemos la fuerza
podemos encontrar la aceleración y esto
es lo que queremos hacer en este vídeo
deducir esta fórmula análoga
para la rotación de la segunda ley de
newton para un objeto que está rotando
en un círculo como esta bola de aquí y
es algo que no solo está rotando en un
círculo está acelerando angular mente
está aumentando la rapidez de su
rotación aunque quizá disminuya la
rapidez de su rotación vamos a deducir
esta fórmula para que si conocemos el
torque podríamos determinar la
aceleración angular de la misma forma
que encontramos la aceleración regular
al conocer la fuerza en la segunda ley
de newton como hacemos esto pues para
tener una aceleración angular vamos a
necesitar una fuerza que sea tangente al
círculo para poder acelerar algo angular
mente necesitamos una fuerza tangencial
ya que esta fuerza me va a ocasionar un
torque digamos que esta es la fuerza que
me ocasiona el torque y ya sabemos cómo
encontrar esta fuerza recuerden que el
torque es igual a r por efe por seno de
teta pero vamos a simplificarlo aquí
diciendo que el ángulo
es de 90 grados de manera que el seno de
theta termine siendo 1 ya que el seno de
90 es igual a 1 y también vamos a
simplificar las cosas diciendo que esta
fuerza es la fuerza neta digamos que hay
sólo una fuerza en este objeto que es
está nuestra fuerza neta y sabemos que
la fuerza neta tiene que ser igual a la
masa del objeto por la aceleración de
ese objeto y me pueden decir vaya qué
novedad esto ya lo sabemos
bueno recuerden que queremos relacionar
el torque con la aceleración angular así
que vamos a escribir la fórmula del
torque si queremos encontrar el torque
de una fuerza recordamos que el torque
va a ser igual a la fuerza que ejerce
ese torque multiplicada por r la
distancia del eje hasta el punto en
donde se aplica la fuerza y en este caso
es todo el radio ya que estamos
aplicando la fuerza hasta este extremo
si esta fuerza se aplicará en alguna
parte un poco más adentro sería
solamente
a esa distancia desde el eje hasta el
punto en donde se ejerce la fuerza que
provoca el torque pero aquí le estamos
aplicando hasta el extremo así que va a
ser esto por todo el radio y también
está el seno del ángulo / efe jr
pero el ángulo entre fr es de 90 grados
así que el seno de 90 grados es igual a
1 así que podemos deshacernos de esto y
ya queda más sencillo el torque ejercido
por esta fuerza f va a ser efe por r y
qué hacemos con esto pues vean aquí aquí
abajo ya tenemos una efe y si son
creativos pueden decir ah pues vamos a
multiplicar ambos lados por r y así
podremos incluir el torque en esta
fórmula multiplico r por el lado
izquierdo y me queda r por efe y
multiplicó r por el lado derecho que me
queda
r por m por la aceleración lo que está
bien ya que ahora tenemos el reporte efe
que es el torque y nos queda que el
torque es igual a r por m
la aceleración pero esto no nos sirve ya
que necesitamos una fórmula que nos
relacione el torque con la aceleración
angular no con la aceleración regular y
con que podemos reemplazar esta
aceleración regular si ustedes recuerdan
cuando hablamos de las variables del
movimiento angular mencionamos la
aceleración tangencial y ésta siempre va
a ser igual a la distancia desde el eje
hasta el objeto que tiene la aceleración
tangencial multiplicado por la
aceleración angular está alfa aquí
tenemos una relación entre alfa y la
aceleración tangencial pero no sirve
para algo esta aceleración tangencial si
nos sirve ya que esta es la fuerza
tangencial aquí tenemos la fuerza
tangencial que va a ser proporcional a
la aceleración tangencial esto es
tangencial y esta fuerza también es
tangencial de manera que puedo
reescribir la aceleración tangencial
como ere por alfa y es lo que vamos a
hacer este lado lo reescribimos como r
por alfa ya que ere por alfa es la
aceleración tangencial así que este
término de aquí es la aceleración
tangencial y ahora tenemos que el torque
va a ser igual a r por m por r por alfa
combinamos las dos erres y nos queda m
por el real cuadrado por alfa mi
aceleración angular y ya estamos cerca
ya tengo una fórmula de la segunda ley
de newton y puedo dejarla así o puedo
poner la de manera que luzca parecida a
esta otra despejó alfa y me queda que la
aceleración angular en esta masa es
igual al torque ejercido en esta masa
entre m la masa por r al cuadrado y esto
es justamente lo que estábamos buscando
vamos a escribirlo aquí el análogo
rotacional de la segunda ley de newton
es
que entre este término de acá m por r al
cuadrado y esto a que se parece pues
cumple el mismo propósito que la masa en
la fórmula de la aceleración regular de
la segunda ley de newton regular y
recuerden que esta masa es proporcional
a la inercia del objeto nos dice que tan
difícil es hacer que este objeto se
acelere que tanto se resiste un objeto
al movimiento oa la aceleración a esto
se refiere este término de aquí las
personas usualmente les llaman a esto el
momento de inercia pero este es un
hombre bastante complicado para una idea
de física y para mí suena extraño pero
esto se representa con la letra i
mayúscula y sirve para el mismo
propósito en este denominador es análogo
a la masa nos sirve para indicar la
inercia rotacional del sistema o en
otras palabras algo con una gran inercia
rotacional va a poner resistencia a la
aceleración angular como algo que tiene
mucha inercia
y poner resistencia a la aceleración
regular así que ya sabemos de qué
depende esta bola para una bola al final
de la cuerda su momento de inercia es m
por r al cuadrado esto es el denominador
es el término que nos sirve para la
inercia rotacional para esta masa en
esta cuerda lo que significa que si
tenemos una masa más grande o una cuerda
más larga este objeto sería difícil de
acelerar angular mente difícil de hacer
que rote que comience a dar vueltas y
acelerar estas vueltas y por otra parte
si la masa es pequeña o la longitud de
la cuerda es pequeña va a ser mucho más
sencillo acelerar angular mente esta
masa pero si tenemos una masa muy grande
con una longitud de la cuerda más grande
pues nos va a aumentar el momento de
inercia que es este término de aquí así
que la podemos ver como la inercia
rotacional que me parece es un hombre
mucho más adecuado y muchas personas
comienzan a pensar
que este es un mejor término para esta
idea este término de momento de inercia
es un término histórico y la verdad no
es muy bueno es mejor inercia rotacional
ya que nos describe mejor de qué trata
esta y mayúscula y debemos de conocer
las unidades de esta inercia rotacional
y cómo es masa por radio al cuadrado sus
realidades van a ser kilogramos por
metro al cuadrado estas son las unidades
del momento de inercia y esta es la
fórmula si tenemos una masa puntual y
con esto me refiero a una masa en la
cual toda su masa está viajando en el
mismo radio y gira en un círculo y no
tiene que estar unida a una cuerda esta
podría ser la luna orbitando a la tierra
pero siempre que toda la masa esté en el
mismo radio y viajando en un círculo y
digamos que este radio de esta esfera es
muy muy pequeña al menos comparada con
este radio si este es el caso en donde
prácticamente toda la masa está girando
en un
con el mismo radio esta será la fórmula
para encontrar el momento de inercia y
esto como se puede complicar que es lo
que debemos cuidar bueno aquí sólo
consideramos una fuerza y podemos
imaginar que quizá haya varias fuerzas
actuando en este objeto quizá tenemos
otra fuerza aquí en cuyo caso sólo
debemos considerar la fuerza neta para
asegurarnos de que esto sea igual a m
por a y debemos asegurarnos de usar el
torque neto aquí esta fórmula nos sigue
sirviendo si tenemos varios toques en
este objeto aquí sólo tendremos que usar
el torque neto de todo el sistema vamos
a sumar todos los torques a aquellos
toques que giren o rotten hacia un lado
serán positivos y aquellos torpes que
roten en el lado contrario serán
negativos por lo que tenemos que
asegurarnos de escribir bien los signos
aquí y que hay de la inercia rotacional
qué pasa si nuestro objeto no es tan
sencillo como una sola masa
haríamos en este caso bueno vamos a
verlo vamos a copiar esta fórmula de acá
nos deshacemos de todo esto y digamos
que tenemos este problema loco tenemos
tres masas aquí y tenemos una fuerza en
esta masa que es de 20 newtons hacia
abajo y tenemos otra fuerza de 50
newtons hacia arriba en esta otra masa
todas tienen una separación de 3 metros
y pueden rotar en un círculo y podemos
resolver este problema con la fórmula
que acabamos de deducir y digamos que
queremos encontrar cuál es la
aceleración angular para cada una de
estas masas en esta configuración
particular vamos a usar esta fórmula
para la segunda ley de newton en su
forma angular y digamos que la
aceleración angular que es lo que
queremos encontrar va a ser igual al
torque neto y como encontramos el torque
neto aquí tenemos dos fuerzas en
realidad no es tan difícil sólo tenemos
que encontrar el torque en cada una de
las masas individuales y luego sumarlos
como
digamos para encontrar un vector neto
sumar cada uno individualmente pero esto
no va a ser 50 menos 20 estos son todos
que tenemos que usar la fórmula del
torque para cada uno de ellos y no usar
la fuerza así que vamos a tener que
multiplicar cada una de estas fuerzas
por el radio que les corresponde así que
no traten de poner este 50 directamente
aquí necesitamos multiplicarlo por una r
cual r tengan cuidado quizás podrían
pensar que es de 3 metros pero no r
siempre se mide a partir del eje de
rotación que es el centro hasta el lugar
en donde se aplica la fuerza así que el
torque para este 50 va a ser 50 por tres
más tres más 399 metros por 50 newtons y
ahora ya tenemos el torque no tenemos un
torque hasta que multiplicamos la fuerza
por una r ya tenemos el torque para los
50 newtons y cuál será el torque para
los 20 newtons pues va a ser 20 newtons
pero no puedo dejar solito este 20
tenemos que multiplicarlo por r y cuál
va a ser esa r no va a ser 3 siempre va
a ser la distancia del eje de rotación
hasta el lugar en donde se aplica la
fuerza que es 3 + 36 son seis metros y
muchas personas se ponen contentas de
llegar a este punto se acordaron de
multiplicar por la r ponen aquí uno más
y son felices pero se van a equivocar no
podemos poner un más aquí vean que esta
fuerza de 50 newtons está intentando
hacer que el sistema rote en sentido
antihorario la fuerza de 50 newtons
intenta que todo esto se mueva hacia acá
pero la fuerza de 20 newtons está
tratando de hacer que el sistema rote
hacia acá abajo en sentido horario se
están oponiendo por lo que vamos a tener
un torque de distinto signo
en estas dos fuerzas
voy a representar el torque de la fuerza
de 20 newtons como un torque negativo y
esa es la convención que normalmente
elegimos todo lo que se mueva en sentido
horario va a ser negativo y lo que se
mueve en sentido antihorario va a ser
positivo
pero no importa cual convención elijan
estos van a tener signos diferentes así
que hay que tener cuidado aquí y este es
nuestro torque neto como encontramos la
inercia rotacional o el momento de
inercia pues vimos del ejemplo anterior
que el momento de inercia de una masa
puntual que es una masa que se mueve en
un círculo o de que toda la masa se
mueve en un radio particular va a ser m
por r al cuadrado pero aquí tenemos tres
masas y quizás piensen que esto es
difícil pero no lo es tanto todo lo que
tenemos que hacer es decir que el
momento total de inercia va a ser la
suma de todos los momentos de inercia
individuales así que vamos a sumar todos
los momentos de inercia individuales
el momento de inercia de la primera masa
es si es de un kilogramo será de un
kilogramo por r al cuadrado y cuál es r
esto es lo que significa vamos a tener m
uno por r uno al cuadrado
m2 x r 2 al cuadrado más m3 x r 3 al
cuadrado y continuamos si es que tenemos
más masas aquí la sumamos todas y nos va
a quedar el momento de inercia total
para un sistema de masas así que aquí lo
seguimos haciendo la r para esta primera
masa va a ser 99 metros ya que esta es
la distancia del eje hasta donde se
encuentra esta masa 9 metros al cuadrado
más la masa 2 que es de 2 kilogramos por
su distancia que es de 6 metros 6 metros
al cuadrado continuamos y ahora tomamos
esta masa 3 que es de 3 kilogramos y la
multiplicamos por su radio que es de 3
metros 3 metros al cuadrado esta será su
contribución al momento de inercia oa la
inercia rotacional sin calculamos todo
esto en una calculadora nos va a dar que
la aceleración angular va a ser igual a
1.83 radiales por segundo al cuadrado
es la tasa a la cual este objeto se va a
acelerar si comienza en reposo comenzará
a tomar velocidad en esta dirección y
comenzará a aumentar su velocidad cada
vez más estas fuerzas mantienen el
torque que están ejerciendo en resumen
así como tenemos la segunda ley de
newton que relaciona fuerzas con
aceleración esta versión angular de la
segunda ley de newton relaciona torque
con la aceleración angular y en el
denominador no tenemos a la masa sino a
la inercia rotacional o al momento de
inercia lo que nos va a decir qué tan
difícil es acelerar angular mente un
objeto y podemos encontrar el momento de
inercia de una masa puntual como m por r
al cuadrado y el momento de inercia de
una colección de masas puntuales lo
vamos a encontrar sumando las
contribuciones individuales de cada una
de las masas del sistema